la sorpresiva renuncia de Boris Johnson
como diputado del partido conservador
del que fue jefe Hasta hace menos de un
año significa y se traduce en un momento
político bien importante para el Reino
Unido Johnson aduce que fue forzado a
tomar esta decisión porque el comité de
privilegios del parlamento que estaba
investigando si el ex Primer Ministro
había mentido deliberadamente al
parlamento a la cámara de los comunes
sobre el partygate según ha dicho
Johnson iba a ser forzado por la puerta
de atrás iba a ser forzado a salir en
una declaración de esta noche de
renuncia Johnson dice entre otras que el
único propósito de este comité de
privilegios desde el principio ha sido
encontrarme culpable independientemente
de los hechos Esta es la definición de
una corte canguro y agrega también en
otra parte que esto sienta un precedente
peligroso e inquietante la pregunta
ahora por supuesto es sí Boys Johnson
termina o no su carrera política porque
sin duda es uno de los hombres más
populares pero al mismo tiempo
controvertidos también por supuesto en
esta carta Johnson dice que se siente
muy triste dejar el parlamento por lo
menos por ahora y no da más pistas sobre
su carrera política Lo cierto es que esa
es la gran pregunta qué va a pasar ahora
con Boris Johnson especialmente de Cara
a las elecciones generales posiblemente
a finales del 2024 en el que Boris
Johnson era la gran Esperanza para su
partido Así que Johnson Aunque mantiene
una altísima popularidad recordemos tuvo
que renunciar tuvo que dar un paso al
costado por una cadena de escandalosos
especialmente por los del partygate en
la que él reconoció que rompió las
reglas del confinamiento por el covid 19
la salida de Johnson ha sido esta noche
todo menos útil porque aprovechó en esta
declaración en esta carta para criticar
la gestión del actual Primer Ministro
Richie sunak a quien acusó de cambiar el
rumbo del partido conservador